the 1996 sci-fi comedy mars attacks is a
movie for the kid in
all of us but if you watched it when you
were an actual kid
you may have missed out on some of the
cleverest parts
fortunately we're here to guide you
through them all
if there's one thing that hollywood
loves it's scouring
every medium known to men for
established ideas whether they're from
books tv shows comics games toys or
other movies
so which of these inspired mars attacks
as the opening credits inform us
it's based upon mars attacks a property
of the tops company
in case you need help interpreting that
description mars attacks is one of the
very few movies that was adapted from a
line of trading cards
and these weren't just any old trading
cards in 1962 tops released a series of
cards with art by
veteran pulp fiction artist norman
saunders which were based on drawings by
golden age comic artists bob powell and
wally wood
saunders was hired after tops got the
idea from wood's cover for an issue of
the comic book weird science
wood was no stranger to controversy
after working on
tales from the crypt which was so
horrifying that it landed his bosses in
front of a senate
subcommittee history repeated itself in
the mars attacks card's violence
delighted children and horrified parents
who demanded that tops pulled them from
the shelves
but the memory still lingered with a
generation of kids
and the movie adaptation recreates
several images directly from its
inspiration
including the herd of flaming cows that
opens the film
director tim burton and screenwriter
jonathan gems have made
no secret that they rotted their brains
out watching hundreds of sci-fi movies
in their youths
as a result attentive audiences might
recognize several scenes inspired by the
drive-in flicks of the 50s and 60s in
mars attacks
when sarah jessica parker as natalie
tries to describe the martian's flying
saucer
the best she can come up with is a giant
hubcap
that's likely a reference to legendarily
terrible director ed wood
as it's been speculated that he used
hubcaps as flying saucers in plan 9 from
outer space
that would have been on burton's mind as
he just made the biopic
ed wood a few years earlier another
notable reference occurs when the
martians abduct professor kessler and
experiment on him by lopping off his
head and keeping it alive with a
headband attached to a series of metal
rods and discs
trash cinema fans may recognize that
apparatus from the brain
that wouldn't die which was featured on
an episode of mystery science theater
3000.
there's also a reference to a more
prestigious movie stanley kubrick's dr
strangelove which satirized the cold war
by portraying america's leaders as a
bunch of bloodthirsty crackpots
mars attacks features an homage to
strange love's famous war room which
burton renders even more cartoonish in
his version
the connections between mars attacks and
sci-fi b movies are
fairly obvious but burton also had some
other
bigger budget movies in mind in the 70s
producer erwin allen hit it
big with the blockbuster disaster flicks
the poseidon adventure and
the towering inferno they combined
ensemble casts of major stars with
spectacular disaster effects
burton called them celebrities getting
killed movies
soon imitators were everywhere from
earthquake to avalanche to the airport
series
which inspired the classic parody
airplane mars attack spoofs the allen
formula by featuring a huge
cast of celebrities whose characters
each react to the disaster in their own
way
the actors on screen were some of the
biggest stars of the time like
michael j fox sarah jessica parker glenn
close
and the then current james bond pierce
brosnan
there are also plenty of stars from
decades earlier
like jack nicholson joe don baker and
singer tom jones as himself the cast
seems even more star-studded now as the
likes of jack black natalie portman and
ray j were mostly unknown at the time
but looking back now
they're some of the biggest names in the
movie
two more stars of mars attacks pay
tribute to yet another movie genre
in the 70s hollywood woke up to the
potential of african-american audiences
with a
flood of low-budget action-packed movies
that were dubbed
black exploitation two of the genre's
biggest stars were pam greer and jim
brown
who appear in mars attacks as ex-husband
and wife byron and luis
greer got her start as a switchboard
operator at the low budget studio aip
before director jack hill got her in
front of the cameras
resulting in cult classics like coffee
and foxy brown
as for brown before he started acting he
earned spots in both the pro
and college football halls of fame for
his career as a running back for the
syracuse orangemen
and then the cleveland browns he
parlayed his gridiron success into an
acting career in both blaxploitation
and prestigious studio films including
the war classic the dirty dozen
even though greer and brown ran in
similar circles
mars attacks was actually their first
movie together when it arrived in 1996
but it wouldn't be their last as that
same year they teamed up with several
other blaxploitation icons for original
gangstas
heavyweight champion of the world
a major reason that mars attacks is so
much
fun is thanks to tim burton's deeply
idiosyncratic filmmaking
you can see the fingerprints of his
style everywhere
natalie portman as the president's board
morbid daughter
for example could be the twin sister of
lydia from beetlejuice
burton also puts his trademark curlicue
design
over everything from the martian spy's
dress to the gangplank on the saucer
which
unfolds like the curly hill in the
nightmare before christmas
burton also made sure to take some of
his closest collaborators along for the
ride
sarah jessica parker had just worked
with him on ed wood
while sylvia sydney had played the
caseworker in beetlejuice
fresh off of batman returns danny devito
shows up as a sleazy gambler
and the martian spy is even played by
burton's then girlfriend lisa marie
there are also plenty of familiar names
behind the camera like colleen atwood
who's designed costumes for nearly all
of burton's movies
and composer danny elfman who's worked
on almost every burton film as well
tim burton is known for creating
timeless on-screen worlds that exist
somewhere out of sync with reality and
that holds true in mars attacks
as you'd expect from a tribute to 50
sci-fi and 70s disaster movies
mars attacks is temporarily all over the
place
the military is all decked out in
vietnam war era uniforms and gear
and at one point a general talks on a
walkie talkie the size of a blimp
even though cell phones had been on the
market for years when the movie came out
the hippies who greet the martian
landing are 60s flower children
while the martian assassin hides her
enormous cranium
under a 50 style beehive hairdo lucas
hawes's richie looks like he could have
walked out of a 90s smashing pumpkins
concert
and as for sarah jessica parker her hair
and fashion sense couldn't
possibly be any more 60s neither could
her tv studio with its groovy polka
dotted papasan chairs and a can of the
discontinued soft drink
tab on the table for the most part mars
attacks
is the farthest thing from subtle but it
does actually contain a few
subtle details that you'll need an adult
sized attention span to catch
for instance when michael j fox says tv
reporter jason stone goes out to cover
the martian landing with his partner
natalie
he's sporting a very silly looking tie
covered in donuts
that accessory isn't just there to make
him look silly when the martian
commander delivers his first message to
the people of earth on tv
he moves his hand in a circle one
character recognizes it as the
international sign of the donut
so it's not a stretch to think that
jason's trying to make a good impression
on the one thing he knows for sure the
martians like
but even if that interpretation is
correct it probably doesn't matter as
far as jason or
anyone else is concerned the martians
pretty quickly
make it clear that they're not
interested in making new friends when
they open fire on the crowd
natalie grabs jason's hand in the hopes
of getting to safety but then she finds
out that his hand is all she's grabbed
as the martians have vaporized the rest
of him
mars attacks is rated pg-13 for sci-fi
fantasy violence and brief sexuality
and while kids may delight in the
over-the-top violence
a lot of the more suggestive material is
likely to go right over their heads
for instance martin short appears as
presidential press secretary jerry ross
who we see cruising around washington in
the limo just before the martian landing
he chats up some scanly clad ladies on a
street corner who ask him if he's
interested
in a date kids might imagine he's about
to buy them dinner but
adults should have no trouble
recognizing the ladies as
street walking sex workers the martians
aren't obviously paying attention as
well since they send their assassin to
pose as a sex worker herself so that
jerry will let her into the white house
and it's hard to imagine even the
youngest viewers misunderstanding the
situation when
jerry jumps on her with his tongue
waggling and knocks her onto the
heart-shaped bed in his secret seduction
room
and if you pay close attention to the
dialogue there's another inside joke for
the adults in the audience
especially the baby boomers and history
buffs
jerry describes the hidden bedroom as
the kennedy room
named after president john f kennedy who
was infamous for his many alleged
extramarital affairs
including one with superstar marilyn
monroe
pam greer's character louise has her
hands full raising her two sons cedric
and neville
while working full time as a bus driver
one day on a route
she drives past the arcade and sees her
boys happily shooting at video game
aliens when they're supposed to be at
school
she then yanks them out of the arcade
and disciplines them in front of a whole
bus of passengers for wasting their time
playing games when they're supposed to
be
learning
later though when cedric and neville are
on a school trip at the white house
they get ambushed by some real life
martians they steal some of the invaders
ray guns and start
firing away just like they did while
playing the arcade game
they equip themselves well against the
actual martians even saving the
president's life
kids may not recognize the underlying
message here but it's a fantasy that
plenty of them have probably had at some
point you see
despite their mom's worries cedric and
neville didn't rot out their brains at
the arcade
instead they learned the skills that
made them heroes in real life
the invading aliens seem completely
unstoppable for most of mars attacks
as they obliterate all of earth's armies
but the plucky richie
finally finds an unexpected solution
when he discovers that his grandmother's
yodeling music
makes the martians heads explode and he
then starts broadcasting it
around the world for kids that probably
seems like just an appropriately silly
way to take out a very silly threat but
the well-read adult may recognize the
twist from a classic alien invasion
story
in h.g wells's 1897 novel the war of the
worlds
the earth's military forces are
similarly helpless against a martian
invasion
but then one day the martians have all
dropped dead
slain by bacteria that they were
unprepared to handle
as it turns out the martians immune
systems are vulnerable to the diseases
that humans have learned to take for
granted
the aliens in mars attacks are equally
vulnerable to earth's infections but
in this case they're infected by ear
worms as slim whitman's yodel on indian
love call
ends up being the key to earth's victory
in this
wonderful tribute to mid-century kitsch
is there any better ending than a
decades-old broadway song saving the day
what's killing them i think it must be
my music
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one